anyone else wants to join and we have
too many technical difficulties i'm
trying to live stream
echo yeah so turn down your uh phone or
your
your clubhouse james turn down your
volume out of your headset
but leave it um leave it unmuted
and then ava can you tell us if you can
still hear us so i can't actually turn
off the entire
clubhouse volume yeah just mute it as
much as you can that's fine
turns out that i cannot yeah let's see
so just for everyone joining us on
youtube we're talking with dr james
beacham
who is a member of the atlas
collaboration at the large hadron
collider
a past guest on the into the impossible
podcast two-time guest
on the into the impossible podcast you
can see him in our theories of
everything conversation that we had
this past summer with stephan alexander
and max tegmark
mutual friends of ours um and
that was over the summer and theories of
everything before that we had a
conversation about
uh theories of everything being explored
by
experiments of everything do we need an
enormous
solar system-sized particle accelerator
to discover new physics and maybe
the answer is no if the current existing
current circular collider aka cern
uh is working well or lhc is working
well enough so that's what i wanted to
discuss today with dr james beacham who
you will know from the movie
chasing einstein many other venues he's
a popular
eiser of science uh last time we spoke
you were maybe working on a book
is that still true james still in the
pipeline yes
that's awesome well that'll be
phenomenal to get from you so we're
live also on clubhouse and we've got a
bunch of people on youtube
so welcome everybody while you're up
here if you're on
youtube or you can access james follow
him up on stage in ava2 uh
follow her and follow her on twitter as
well as james on twitter who is at jb
beacham at uh if you have any big clout
coins yet james
you have any big clout yet creator no
actually i'm really really bad at
twitter and i i'm not trying to build
any kind of following so you can follow
me but i'm really bad at the whole game
so that's true maybe maybe i'll maybe
i'll be
inspired to try to grow a following if
there's some kind of you know
cryptocurrency involved yeah maybe yeah
okay i'm gonna mute um sorry so i'm
gonna i'm gonna ask so james if you can
mute your microphone too
on clubhouse so mute the clubhouse
microphone i'm going to keep mine active
yeah
and now james say something to the
audience one more time
so i the thing that i need is i need to
be able to turn down uh
clubhouse completely on like so that's
not coming out of the out of the ipad
but it won't let me do that
right you can actually turn it off
completely um yeah so maybe you can
yeah if you can cover it up with
something right it's experimental
physics everybody
ava does that sound better now you can
hear uh james through
my clubhouse and at least okay great
yeah great okay good so we're okay some
kind of annoying echo or anything like
that
they were but i think we fixed it um
so on youtube let me check in with my
youtube friends
hopefully they are enjoying it as well
um
and uh so first i wanted you to kind of
give an overview of what
is um what is the nature of this big
announcement that we woke up to
99 confidence level detection
of potential signature for new physics
first of all
what is this experiment and uh and what
does it mean
to discover new physics before we get
into this particular result that was
discussed today what is the lhcp
experiment and um and what does new
physics mean
yeah so the lhcb experiment is one of
the four
experimental collaborations on the ring
of the large hadron collider so
as everybody probably knows and if you
don't why are you here the large hadron
collider is the largest experiment in
human history
and it's a 27 kilometer circular tunnel
uh that's 100 meters underground on the
border of france and switzerland
and uh in this tunnel we use
superconducting magnets that we have to
keep colder than outer space
to accelerate protons to almost the
speed of light and then we slam them
into each other millions of times a
second
and we then collect the debris of these
collisions
to uh to collect a huge amount of data
and then sift through people like me
sift through this data
to see if we've uh found any evidence of
new discoveries new particles that could
completely revolutionize our
understanding of nature
or if we've seen the uh expectation from
the standard model or this kind of thing
this you know the
background expectation if you will the
noise and so on that ring there's four
different points
both on the ring there's two beams that
go in opposite directions
and at four different points on the beam
we uh we cross them and
we collide the protons and at each one
of these four
points we build a gigantic detector and
by gigantic i mean really gigantic so
the one that i work on is called atlas
and it's six stories high and it's 46
meters long it's like a gigantic soda
can tipped on its side and filled with
complicated electronics
and those so there's another one that's
like atlas that is that is complementary
to
it uh it's called cms so atlas and cms
were both designed to be more or less
general purpose detectors meaning that
they were designed to be
sensitive to a very large number of
possible signatures
of new physics and that's important
because
those are the two experiments that
discovered the higgs boson in 2012 so
you know my atlas and cms colleagues and
i discovered the higgs boson hooray
but there are two other experiments on
that ring that were designed for more
specific purposes
that can also obviously do completely
game-changing physics they can
absolutely make discoveries that
completely revolutionize our
understanding of of nature
and so what one of these experiments is
called lhcb
and if atlas and cms are these two
gigantic
cylinders where protons came in from
both sides a collision happens and they
more or less collect everything that
comes out in all directions
with the with a sort of blind spot being
right down the very front part of the
beam we call it
along the beam line then lhcb is
designed
specifically to look for things that
actually go all the way forward so you
have like a proton that comes in
collides
and then the stuff that goes that way
it's a highly
uh it's a highly um uh you know finely
segmented
uh detector that detects everything
going in one direction
so it's very very far forward and the
reason it's designed this way is because
the whole intention of lhcb
as an experiment was to be optimally
sensitive to these
the the the intention of lcb can be
found in the last number
b so the lhcb experiment is designed to
be optimally sensitive to
particles that contain b quarks
sometimes referred to as bottom quarks
and then in some sectors also it's
occasionally referred to as beauty
quirks
that's very that's very specific to like
this one particular type of particle
physics
a lot of us don't use that phrase some
people use the beauty thing i'll be
using b
or bottom probably in this discussion
and b quarks are really interesting
because
they have this really fascinating
property that when they start to bunch
up together
with other quarks into mesons or baryons
these particular mesons and baryons can
actually have non-negligible lifetimes
so this is a little bit getting into the
weeds but just so you know lhcb
was designed to be uh optimally
sensitive to these particular
measurements
having to do with b hadrons and other uh
other kind of
complex meson baryons that you can make
out of these kinds of quarks all that's
important because
it's a perfect example of how the
entirety of the lhc program
has been designed so that everything
fits together in a complementary package
so that we're not
missing anything and you know and this
this
result that came out of lacd today is a
perfect example because
the lhcb experiment again like i said
it's designed to look for these kind of
forward
forward-looking particles that kind of
go down in one direction and then
but the reason that's important is that
those allow you to make
very very precise measurements of the
particular way that these particles
decay
into in certain ratios in certain
directions in certain preferential
places
and so that's basically the crux of
everything behind
why this this uh this result today is so
fascinating
because it points out that for us to be
able to find
new discoveries and to try to push
beyond the standard model of particle
physics
we need to look at every possible place
and so with atlas and cms we look for
you know new big uh you know new big uh
um uh you know big particles that might
show up really heavy ones like
heavy cousins of the higgs boson
gigantic z prime particles quantum black
holes
and so we look for those things but we
also at the same time we look at very
very precise
predictions of this so-called standard
model but
that's sort of the background as to what
lhcb is
yeah so the paper that was released is
in the
uh text box on the youtube description
that i posted
uh so folks want to follow along you can
go to dr brian keating
on youtube you will find there uh
previously a video james beacham from
last summer
uh two videos one a solo episode talking
about future circular colliders
and james is perhaps one of the world's
foremost
proponents exponents expositors of why
we might need
a giant 10 to 20 billion euro
or more experiment and perhaps why that
might not be enough
but arguments for that incredible
machine known as the fcc
are given there uh so that's dr brian
keating that's my youtube channel you
can see a video of us
chatting uh we're also live on clubhouse
uh i posted the link there and they talk
about the standard model of physics and
they talk about
the potential of this strange maison
which is the name of it it's not
a str an adjective right it's not a
strange maison it's a strange
meson uh that emits either potentially
an electron or its anti-matter particle
cousin or antimatter twin if you will
call the positron
or a muon or its antimatter cousin
particle brother twin whatever anti-muon
and uh there is a violation of this
so-called lepton universality
is that related to the conservation of
lepton number
uh and if not what is the meaning of
lepton universality
yeah so there's a connection but it's
not exactly the same thing so
we need to back up a little bit to
really understand the importance of
this result today um and it goes back to
this thing that we were hinting at
earlier where
um uh where it's
somebody let me know if there's like a
weird echo or something like that i can
hear me
coming through the clubhouse thing but i
can't get rid of it anyway so let me
know if it's
it's not understandable and i'll i'll
change um
oh hold on one second james hold on one
second yeah please uh ava
can you uh what we're gonna say and then
i'm gonna add in
phil is joining as well hold on one
second phil
um so ava can you go ahead what are we
going to say that you sound mostly
scratching and it you know like sounds
like things are moving around that's
a bit hard to hear but mostly the
message here so i don't dare interrupt
you
i also might leave in about 10 minutes
so apologies for that if you need
someone else to moderate
okay okay thank you very much uh so we
are
doing on video what i've
i've gotten rid of clubhouse so it
should be okay all right
so we are joined by phil who is uh
wearing a
milwaukee brewer sweatshirt shout out to
phil and the brute crew
how are you doing phil i'm doing pretty
well thank you
and phil are you a member of the team
i'm sorry i'm not super familiar with
with uh with you except for that you
come with james's highest
recommendations
no so i'm not i'm not directly a member
of the team so
uh i am on the lhcp collaboration uh but
i'm not
a direct member of the team i see okay
and can you for the for the record for
the court record can you state your name
and affiliation please
sure so i'm i'm phil hilton uh
uh currently with both university of
birmingham and also university of
cincinnati
uh and currently um migrating to
university of cincinnati oh okay so you
will
change your sweatshirt to a bearcat
correct
is that not the mascot of the uh
of the of the university of cincinnati
are they the bearcats
they are the bearcats yes they are
indeed so we're talking i need to update
i need to update my hoodies
we were talking james was talking a
little bit about conservation laws i do
want to point out i believe
james today is emmy neither's birthday
maybe
our anniversary of her birth really yeah
so yeah please speak a little bit
about that uh but you were saying about
conservation laws about lepton number
lepton universality can you say more
about that yeah
this is a really fascinating thing and
it's i love
this particular field of physics the
sort of subfield that's sort of chasing
down
conservation laws and things like that
um at the very very precise
edges because it speaks to how how
exactly how particle physics and to my
mind you know the broader science world
really progresses
you know we sometimes have in our minds
this notion it's like
the entire of the entirety of the
scientific community can be overthrown
by
you know like a straight white male that
has a eureka moment and then makes a
precise prediction and then you make an
experiment and it finds that thing and
that's the way it goes
science doesn't really work that way and
so that
nowhere is that more apparent than in
this thing we refer to as the standard
model of particle physics
because this thing came together it's
it's arguably the
the most successful intellectual
achievement of humankind because it
makes these wonderful precise
predictions as to how the world should
behave
at the smallest possible levels that
basically all come true
it's like completely like mind-blowing
how how great this
this uh this uh thing is um and
it's but it came together in a
particular way it wasn't again it wasn't
just somebody that sort of by fiat in
like you know 1885
said uh this should work just fine this
this thing you know this is exactly what
the standard model is and this is
exactly what it predicts
that's not how it came together it came
together sort of by fits and starts
somebody observed something just they
saw in a laboratory
and then some theorists said this is
interesting i wonder what that means
maybe it could mean xyz
and then somebody said oh if that's true
then this should
potentially show up in an experiment as
pqr blah blah blah
blah and so this is the way it actually
came through came together over the
history of the 20th century
and it culminated in this thing that we
now refer to as the standard model of
particle physics
but if you look into the details of the
standard model a lot of them a lot of
the stuff that's there that's
fascinating and that corresponds to
sort of like makes these predictions and
then it corresponds to these
measurements that we make
it's just sort of there it's like
there's no real sort of
reason for why some of the values of the
standard model the way they are and some
of the predictions that it makes
some of the ways that it's organized
some of the things just happen to be the
way they are
and so this is why you know this is why
uh we why it's important to be able to
measure everything there is to know
about the the standard model of particle
physics because at the end of the day
just like you're intimating you know
emmy nether if it's the anniversary of
her birth today this is fantastic
because she's
we basically couldn't do what we do uh
at the lhc without any another
because she was the one that observed
that any time it made a key observation
about symmetries
in our equations and particles and
and conservation laws that we would see
in in
uh in reality and so this leads to this
notion that you know anytime you have
some sort of basically a symmetry you
can think of a symmetry
in particle physics as if i have my
equation set up in a
certain way and there's something inside
that i can change in a particular way
and it doesn't change with the final
answer that i get out of it that's a
symmetry
so for example i can put like a you know
if i if for those of you that know math
if i have some kind of standard
differential equation i put some kind of
like
you know some kind of x complex
exponential in there and then i do
particular stuff to it maybe do some
do some uh you know some some squares
and things like that
that won't affect what the final answer
is so this means that there's some kind
of symmetry
inside my my theory and just and they
never pointed out that any time you see
one of these there's a continuous
symmetry it means that you have a
conservation law
so i don't know how much detail we want
to get into that but essentially what it
gets to is the fact that
really what we look for in in the
standard model what we look for in
particle physics are deviations from
these symmetries
or or you know observations of these
symmetries because like i said
there's a there's a large number of
these symmetries you can come up with
you can say oh maybe this is a symmetry
maybe this is a symmetry of nature
and this is the part where to me it's
like it starts to butt
into our understanding as sort of like
humans with what our intuition is it's
like oh yeah of course nature should be
symmetrical
about some kind of thing but it turns
out it's not
there are certain things in standard
model that they you might think if you
were just sort of
you know by first principles i'm going
to design an elegant universe
this should be a symmetry of nature and
it just turns out that our universe just
chooses not to
to to have this particular symmetry you
know there's this the famous example is
cp
symmetry as you know right yeah and so
this is a you know we could talk about
that in more detail but basically yeah
there's this
there's these symmetries that you should
in principle they could be there
and it's just it's not up to us to
choose whether nature right observes or
violates the asymmetries
which have to go in search for
yeah so uh phil can you hear me okay
yeah i can hear you right so this
experiment uses uh muons
and of course the famous uh phrase by i
think it was robbie
said um the discovery of the muon who
ordered that
i think that was robbie was it was so
along james's line um was this something
that was serendipitous
from the get-go in other words was it
thought that this
uh would be detectable and that you had
to look for it and we didn't have
previously enough sensitivity
or was it truly serendipitous in that it
completely was unexpected you didn't
design the lhcb
experiment i know it's not your result
particularly but can you say something
about the design of it was it intended
to go after this effect the way that
the lhc without the bee was intended to
go after the higgs or
or was it something serendipitous like
cp violation
you know uh discovered by accident
perhaps or or
uh can you clarify that sure
so i think um in
in the context of this measurement
exactly itself
uh there have been previous measurements
of this from other
experiments outside of the lhc so for
example bell which was an electron
positron collider where they they look
at this measurement as well
and they saw something that didn't quite
agree with the standard model but the
uncertainty on it was quite large and so
uh not much was thought of it at that
point
um so when lhcd rolled around and we
measured this we weren't really
expecting anything to come out of it but
from the first measurement we actually
saw some sort of deviation
uh which looked like it could be
interesting and so consequently
there are a whole bunch more
measurements that were made and many of
them
saw similar kind of deviations none of
them by themselves a discovery at all
but just
kind of small nigly deviations or
anomalies
and so this started to make it a lot
more interesting so this specific
version
of the analysis which was just recently
released this one was very purposely
gone into because we had seen all these
other deviations and so that's that's
why this particular measurement was made
but in the larger context of lhcb
it was specifically look designed to
look at b physics
and one of the kind of beautiful things
behind b physics and for those of you uh
who are listening
and know that the b quark is also called
the beauty quark that wasn't eat a pun
one one of the very nice thing about b
physics is that you can use it to look
for
um new physics through what we call kind
of indirect measurement so things like
cp violation this is an example of this
but
for example with the decay of the of of
the neutron we knew
about the w and the z boson uh much
earlier
before they were directly discovered and
so this is the entire idea behind
lhcb and the measurements that are done
at lhcp
so to answer your question no we were
not expecting particularly this
but the type of physics that we look at
is oftentimes sensitive to these kind of
indirect
influences of new physics ah interesting
so we're hearing some talk as we often
do about what does it mean to be
99 significant or 3.1
standard deviations my late great
colleague professor hans parr of the
university of california
renowned student of leon letterman and
others at columbia
he used to say at three sigma they'll
invite you to give a colloquium but you
have to pay for it yourself
at five sigma at five sigma they'll
invite you
out and they'll pay for it and that
seven sigma you'll get a nobel prize
invitation to stockholm so phil what
does it mean
uh the 3.1 sigma significance would you
get on a plane if it had a 399
percent chance of going uh of staying in
the air and a one percent chance of
crashing
no i would not uh i it's so
so the official line from the lhc
lhcb collaboration is uh cautiously
optimistic
this is the this is the official line um
i would i would say that um this
analysis by itself uh
you might say that uh okay
this can happen right and it does right
this this happened with atlas and cms
uh with this kind of photon excess at
very high masses
something very similar to this happened
where it looked like maybe there was
something and then
it went away uh i think one of the
interesting things that's coming out of
this
is that there are now a number of
measurements so not just this
measurement but other measurements as
well
which if you do kind of a global
analysis of it which a number of
theorists have done
so for example there are other ratios
you can measure there are other angular
analyses that you can
make that if you take all these kind of
into consideration you can start
seeing some sort of pattern emerge
from the point of making claims about
but you will
talk to a number of theorists who
certainly will say uh that that a global
pattern might be emerging from this
and james uh we were talking a little
bit earlier about
the the need for last summer i should
say we're talking about the need for
you know future experiments some people
are saying in the comments rather
cheekily
send this to sabina because she was
saying you know there's nothing new
that's going to be discovered
we don't need a bigger future circular
collider it's a big waste of money
um and her normal cheerful no i love
sabina she's actually a dear friend
um and she's very extremely important
figure i would say
in in the scientific community but you
know
does this undermine or does this enhance
the the prospects for a new experiment
so it's to me it can only possibly
enhance but
of course you know my opinion on the
whole thing is that the
case for these new machines is already
completely rock solid and anybody that
says otherwise
is thinking about science in the wrong
way so what this can do though is only
enhance
because in a good way right because it
can help you know give a motivation for
for example
a bunch of new people that are
interested in you know working on b
physics to also join
you know the effort to start doing some
studies as to what we could learn
from you know from this type of search
in the future
um but again the key point here is kind
of what phil said and sort of the
official line from
uh from lhcb which is in fact always the
official line with particle physicists
the experimentalists at least
which is cautious optimism right we
always have cautious optimism because
the reason why no one is actually
calling home to mom yet about 3.1
is because we have seen 3.1 sigma
excesses come and then completely
disappear with more data
so we know how this works we have seen
this happen before
so this is the notion of cautious
optimism like phil said though
this is really fascinating cautious
optimism because
if you take you know because it's not
just this as an anomaly that we've seen
or like a you know significant anomaly
there have been
other anomalies in the so-called flavor
sector which is
arguably what this whole kind of thing
is right looking for different
looking for violations in the way that
the standard model treats different
types of leptons or in some cases you
know other
types of quarks and things or you know
other particles like quarks
in this case we have seen other of these
and if you kind of like put them all
together and squint your eyes just right
you can convince your theorist
colleagues that maybe you have like a
you know collectively some kind of
global five sigma
kind of you know suggestion none of us
are saying that's on the experimental
side which is why i think it's important
to have experimentalists
chime in on this whole thing we have
seen these kind of anomalies come and go
this one though is super super
fascinating because like phil said
this particular measurement has been
done multiple times before
and it's always been a little bit off
from what it's supposed to be at first
it was not so off like
with respect to the uncertainties you're
like okay fine that's you know we'll
just
collect more data and then it got a
little bit better and then uncertainty
went down and now it's at the point
where it's actually still off from the
expected value
but the uncertainty is really really low
so that's the whole notion of
cautious optimism we should kind of like
set the stage as to
why this would even mean anything for a
future circular collider
so if you look in just a tiny bit of
detail at what's actually going on here
you're looking at some particular thing
so the process that's actually going on
here phil can talk more about this as an
expert right
but really you have the particular type
of particle that's a b
b plus particles this is a meson that
has a b quark and
is in fact an anti-b cork and then i
think an up quark
and this is kind of sailing along and at
some point something happens inside
where the b
cork turns into an s cork and this is
where you said strange so this is a
strange quark
and that's why it's strange because it's
an s or it's an s because it's strange
and then that's that's something that
made it turn into that
could be a few different things one is
that's only possible if you have these
these like very very heavy particles
that participate
in this so-called kind of loop diagram
in there that allows this to happen
and then what happens in that kind of
loop is as that happens you get for
example w bosons and maybe a z boson
and then it spits off two leptons and
this is what you were saying brian it
could end up being either electrons or
you know electron positron pair or a
muon anti-muon pair
and so that's that's possible for that
to happen just given the standard model
but it's extremely rare and you can also
calculate that
really really precisely that we all we
know quite a bit about that
the problem is that we see this not so
so then the thing you might then
so the test here is actually this notion
of universality right
where it's like you might think that
this thing that comes down the leptons
there's no reason to think that there
should
preferentially decay to electron
positron versus muon anti-neuron
or for to be complete cow or anti-tau
which is another heavy cousin of these
of these but in this
case seen is that yes a little bit
preferentially
the this decay tends to be accompanied
by
uh and not so much muon anti-muon
and i think i'm frozen here please let
me know if you can hear me i hear you
okay so yeah so that so but then so that
you start to think
what is making this happen there is
there's something else in this little
blob
this sort of unknown blob that is not
just these heavy particles like
w's and z's the ones we know and love or
so because just given those standard
model particles in there you should get
electron positron and muon antimony at
the same rate there's no reason to think
otherwise we've never seen any violation
of this anywhere else
in this case there is some kind of
preferential decay and
one way to explain that is if there's
some new particle
some completely wild exotic thing that
could be in there
that is somehow making it so that for
example it's too sticky
inside for for muons and it lets off
electrons and positrons at them at a
higher rate
and this could be for so this is the
place where the potential discovery is
right that's
that's that's the money thing that's the
money blob right there
it could be for example a new force
carrying particle
like a z prime which would be totally
revolutionary because there's no other
other forces in the standard model
it could be something called a lepto
cork this is a bizarro particle that
both couples to leptons and quarks it's
totally weird
so the and the mass scale of this
particle the
could in fact be something extremely
high because it's sort of like in this
loop here
and you know phil can probably talk more
about this but because it's in this loop
it in fact can have a very very high uh
high mass this particle
and because it doesn't actually we can't
actually discover it
directly in that particular process and
for example this in this in
intermediate particle this completely
wild new thing could potentially be
i don't know a lepto cork with like 10
tev we can't make a 10 tev
lepto cork directly at the lac which
means we would need
another machine we don't need further
justification for a bigger machine but
this would be extra justification
very cool so phil has muted himself but
i do want to ask him to unmute
uh because i want to ask you phil when
you do these types of experiments when
one does these types of experiments
what what is the extent that physicists
such as ourselves will rely
on symmetry in other words we'll do a
test that is designed to be
a null result actually in order to
test our understanding of the particular
peccadillos of the experiment itself in
other words
what sorts of tests do you subject data
to maybe again not speaking you're not a
member of this team that was announcing
today
you work on the same instrument you're
uh familiar with the techniques
what sorts of techniques you use to go
to assurance
to prove as feynman says uh that you
haven't been fooled because we all know
that we are the easiest
people to fool so can you talk a little
bit about the types of null tests jack
dantes
etc and then um and then we'll come back
sure absolutely so uh
one of one of the kind of
uh really nice things about this result
is that it's a ratio of basically two
different processes as james said
one is where you have a b plus maison
and it's decaying into a
k plus meson and then mu plus mu minus
so muon and an anti-muon
and then you do the exact same thing
except it's decaying into an electron
and a positron uh and by taking the
ratio of these two results from a
point of view of theory a lot of
uncertainties that entered that are
introduced
cancel out so this is from a theoretical
point of view a very nice measurement to
make
from an experimental point of view
electrons and muons
act very very differently in our
detector and so this means you really
have to take that into account
so from the experimental point of view
we actually don't do
a single ratio like this what we do is
actually a double ratio
and we utilize and rely upon
actually leptin universality in a
different process where we know that it
does hold and where we know that any
type of kind of new physics
would be entering at a rate that that
wouldn't really matter in the
measurement
so in this particular measurement we use
what's called the jsi so it's a bound
charm anti-charm state and this decays
into muons and electrons and we actually
use this type of decay
to validate the measurement itself as
well wow
hopefully that answers your question
yeah it definitely did
uh james we hear them talking about new
physics um
and maybe even a fifth force i wasn't
aware that this would necessarily imply
the existence of a fifth force but maybe
rather
a new decay channel an additional in the
same way that the observations
made by uh cs uh wu uh chen singh wu
back in 1957 they didn't reveal a new
force of nature they revealed that
the electoral that the weak force had uh
certain parity violating properties
um so to what extent is that actually
accurate that this would be a new force
of nature or rather than just a new
property of existing
particles found in nature
is actually a consequence of a new
particle that would be a new force
carrying particle
that's the kind of simplest answer
because the only you know the standard
model
discovers or sorry describes three of
the known forces of nature
like so wonderfully well just like oh it
does such a fantastic job
with three of the known forces of nature
it says nothing about gravity which you
know we know that it's incomplete
but each one of these forces of nature
has so-called force carrying particles
associated with it
and so for the electromagnetic force you
know it's the photon and you're all
bathed in photons right now so that's
the force carrying particle of v m
uh for the weak force there there are
these three gauge bosons or force
carrying particles the w plus w minus
and the z
and then for the for the strong force
there's a bunch of gluons and they're
all basically similar properties
um but that w and the z are really
interesting because these the the weak
force has this really unique property
where it has these three different gauge
bosons and these are so-called force
carrying particles
and in fact this whole notion of lepton
flavor universality
is very deeply connected to things like
gauge bosons it's
it's really fascinating because there's
certain symmetries in the standard model
these
so-called symmetries that you know that
we can measure that are there because of
the particular gauge structure of the
standard model
the particular mathematical structure
and there's other ones like this lepton
universality this is sort of accidental
in fact we just call them
accidental symmetries they just happen
to be preserved
up until the moment that somebody sees a
deviation from that then they'll be
violated right
and so the z is really important for
that so the z boson back at lap one of
the most f
fascinating things that left did which
was the experiment in the tunnel
before the lhc was there was the fact
that they measured
the z boson uh branching ratios of the
leptons down to extreme precision and
they're basically all the same
so this indicates that z as a particle
is really motivating for basically new
things in the future because if there is
a new force of nature
it would make sense that it could have a
gauge boson similar to a z
so we refer to this as a z prime or
sometimes a dark photon or things like
that
and that's actually a very fascinating
side uh project because
it's something that phil and i both work
on in separate ways
uh looking for the so-called dark
photons in particular ways
but but if you were to have so one of
the ways you could explain this
particular
this violation is if that again that
thing in the blob there that makes this
you know this b turn into an s plus a
couple of photo
sorry a couple of electrons
preferentially over a couple of muons
something else in that blob could in
fact be a z prime particle
and if the z prime particle exists then
it could be a new force carrier so
that again that that's something that we
can't necessarily directly discover
at the lhc because number one we haven't
seen any evidence
for direct production at say atlas and
cms for these z primes but instead what
we do is we could
indicate we could see conclusively at
lhcb
and potentially at atlas and cms i know
for a fact that atlas and cms
have similar results and complementary
results to this lcb one in the pipeline
right now
with let's cross our fingers that they
will be out you know sometime later this
year
we don't really know its timelines are
different but if we were to see
so we haven't seen any z primes of atlas
to cms or lhcp
to sort of directly produce and then
decay into something which is really
what
atlas and cms are good at right if if
the lhc smacks together two protons
a big fat particle sits there for a
second and then decays to something
immediately
we'll we'll find it we haven't seen any
of these so far so instead we have this
sort of hint this indirect hint
and we can then say conclusively if this
turned into say a five or a seven sigma
thing
we could say conclusively this is a new
effect one of the explanations could be
a force carrying particle
we won't be able to say this
definitively with just
this particular measurement but this is
a perfect example of how all these
experiments are complementary right
lhcb can for example see something
that's like a big sort of hint
and like a conclusive sort of evidence
of something new and
everybody goes okay drop everything look
directly at this you know build a
gigantic uh you know 100 kilometer uh
tunnel
a new new a new detector i'm sorry a new
accelerator a bunch of detectors
and make sure this is exactly what
you're looking for in addition to
everything else i i really like the way
it all fits together
and phil uh we're getting questions in
the audience about uh on youtube at
least we'll take
uh questions from clubhouse as well but
i remind you to go to dr brian keating
on youtube if you want to see
some of the links we're discussing and
see these uh
physicist faces it's nice to connect a
person to a voice
uh we got about 15 minutes before it
gets super late over there in europe
uh and we have to go to take care of
other
less less existential items like uh
picking up kids
uh but maybe i'll stay on clubhouse for
a little bit just the same
uh uh so phil some are asking about
implications for dark matter dark energy
new forces james mentioned a little bit
about you know dark photons or
um i forget the other term you use james
but phil can you talk a little bit about
implications in cosmology
from the very small to the very biggest
sorry brian could you repeat that last
bit there that kind of broke up for me
there
oh just wondering if you can comment on
the implications for cosmology
potentially if this result is confirmed
yeah so the so first of all the
current is i wanted to touch very
quickly on what james said about some
atlas results in cms results
uh also kind of being consistent with
this anomaly
uh so they have upcoming results but
they also have previous results which
when you put them as i said into kind of
a
a global picture of everything you can
start to maybe get an idea of what kind
of force this would be
if it truly is new force and so james
mentioned a z
prime or something like a dark photon
this is certainly a possibility
there are some other ones out there that
um in the current kind of fits of all
these anomalies together
are preferred so for example james
mentioned already the lepto cork this is
a pretty crazy
force which kind of is able to
to interact with both leptons and quarks
at the same time
and this is actually a very nicely
preferred model
another type of model that's preferred
is uh
a particle that would be similar to the
higgs boson the fact that it's what we
call a scalar particle
but it's different in the fact that it
would carry color
from the uh from from quantum
chromodynamics and so this would really
be some sort of exotic particle
now the question is how are these how
these possibly could these be connected
with with dark matter in the dark sector
the answer is yes but the problem is
that we won't necessarily
know how they're connected from just uh
terrestrial based experiments
so you could make some guesses about how
it would be connected and you can
certainly make a lot of speculation
about how it would be connected
but to really be able to kind of make
conclusive
um statements about that what you would
really want to be able to do is see how
dark matter directly interacts with with
the matter that we have here on earth
so it gives you plenty of chance to
speculate but you wouldn't necessarily
be
able to say anything conclusive about it
that's for sure got it
okay i'm going to open now up to
clubhouse for the
uh for the next question there were some
hands raised right i wouldn't
yeah go for it i want to show something
really quickly just to yep yeah exactly
get up a nice question i'll just mention
here jumping on what phil said
so this notion of chasing down anomalies
and chasing down
uh you know deviations from expectation
is yeah it has a very long history not
just in physics but you know even like
in the you know the sort of like left
vanilla cb
or lhc days right and so this is you
know phil pointed out a good
example of the you know the other
complementary measurements from atlas
and cms
i also i should probably just mention
explicitly for example
uh last year atlas my experiment um
released a result that was really
fascinating looking for a similar type
of
uh lepton uh flavor universality by you
know kind of a violation of this
universality
with a very kind of novel way uh looking
for you know
top quarks as they decay to left uh two
w quarks and then particular types of
leptons
it's a little bit you know the details
you can get in the weeds if you want but
really what it is it's a fantastic
thing because this is in fact they did
we did not see
uh violation from this universality
which was in fact contrary to what had
just a hint of something that had seen
way back in the left days so you know
it's a again
particle physics is uh is a marathon
it's not a sprint you have to be very
patient with these things so this is for
example
i think it was a 2.7 sigma excess or
deviation
from back in the left days that just
last year was finally ruled out and said
no in fact it's consistent so this is
the notion of cautious optimism right
it's like yes we're all
you know raising our eyebrows like on a
scale of 1 to 10 if 10
is like a discovery you know this
eyebrow raises about like a you know
maybe like
a four or something like that we're
keeping an eye on
okay great so we have a hand up we have
radoslav is in clubhouse so raise your
hand if you'd like to
speak with phil or with james beacham or
myself
write us up go for it thank you
james and phil thank you very much for
taking the time to go through the result
uh i'll be i'll be quick a few questions
here look at the plot
on page eight figure eight it looks like
the bar
measured this and agreed directionally
with what
you're seeing at lhcp but the bell grant
that our bars were massive
was on the other side but bars i recall
was slack right and that was running
about 20 years ago and then the other
couple of questions as i recall before
was an attempt to try and understand
why there's more matter in the universe
as opposed to antimatter
given that we think some hints might be
contained in these uh
mesons so is there any uh any potential
explanation
that could revolve around why there's a
proponent of matter as opposed to
antimatter and and lastly i gather the
chao and also decays into neutrinos
and i'm wondering it could there also be
perhaps a connection to uh
to neutrino oscillations that we don't
quite understand yet that may be giving
rise to yes
great thank you uh james or phil do you
want to take
that either one of you guys can crack
out sounds like a great fill question
guys
go for it sure sure yeah sure so
uh you're right so if you take if you
take a look at this figure uh there are
results from babar and then
also from bell both of these experiments
are b
physics experiments so in other words
they're specifically focused on looking
at b mesons
uh and as you mentioned uh one of the
things that they're looking at
is this this um cp violation in beta
case
and how this connects to the idea of
this matter anti-matter asymmetry and
whether uh in these types of decays you
can have
enough violation like this to basically
account for the matter antimatter race
imagery in the universe and so this is
certainly one of the big picture
questions that's a driving force for all
of these experiments like babar
bell and lhcd as well so in that context
babar bell and lhcb from a kind of
physics viewpoint
all are focusing on very similar things
they're very different of course in in
the setup and the fact that lhcb
is on a collider where we we're where we
collide protons
and typically for b physics experiments
this can be a little bit hard to do
because it's a much
noisier environment and so in this
context lhcb
is different this is a disadvantage but
there are also a lot of advantages that
you have as well in terms of the amount
of data that you can collect
and the type of data you can collect as
well
so in context of the bar and the bell
results they didn't have quite as much
data
available to them and you'll see that
within the data that they have
the bar and bell are consistent
whereas the lhcp results are not
you can also look at some other results
from bell and babar
that are related to these measurements
you can look at them in these different
bins of what's called q squared so this
is basically the
the mass squared of the of the two
leptons so
the the mu plus mu minus uh or the e
plus e minus
uh and you can look at them in these
bins and in this case
actually you will see that some of the
results uh from previous experiments
also see
this discrepancy but typically they will
have significantly larger uncertainty
this has to do with the number of events
that they've seen
and also how well they can peg down the
uncertainties of their experiment
so i think that answered some of them i
think there was one more that slipped my
mind that you had asked
neutrino oscillations and and the count
decay right
isn't the b plus the case into account
and um
that ultimately goes into a lepton and
neutrino
so what we see here on so in terms of
the lifetime of these particles in our
detector
we see in this case the k plus we don't
see the decay of the k
plus so we will just see the k plus
itself and now it's decay
so in this particular experimental setup
the decay of the k plus
uh is not particularly relevant and the
reason for this is because
much cleaner measurement that's great i
didn't realize that
yes yes so actually that's why so
this is a testament to how wonderfully
these detectors are
you know are designed that you can
actually do something like that right
right very good thanks roslav uh are
there any other questions in clubhouse
we can take that otherwise
we have some more questions on youtube
and i want to remind folks
uh to please uh look into following
james beacham on
different social channels he's not super
active by his own admission
but i find him to be quite entertaining
to follow in all things
uh but he's uh he's very shy so you have
to get him out of his shell but
please subscribe to the uh you can find
them on facing einstein which is a
wonderful documentary you can find that
on
uh on itunes and on youtube and
it features my very good friend elena
april who is uh
the margaret burbidge visiting professor
of physics just a year ago i can't
believe how much has happened in that
year
she's also featured on my channel so
please do subscribe give a thumbs up
leave a comment
uh here and this will be on itunes and
all the other places you get a podcast
later on
phil ilton where can people find you
follow me
sorry please do fill up my head because
that's the only place that i that i give
like
a broadcast tower for what i do even
though i'm not so active that's my
broadcast tower
i do not have any social media accounts
but you can email me if you would like
that explains your phenomenal
productivity compared to me at least
um so these these decays are really
interesting
and uh and i i you know maybe i'll say
controversially that it seems like
uh maybe you'll be even more shocking
than the higgs discoveries that you
uh and your teammates made in that if
you discover a new force well that's a
lot better than a
than kind of an old force that we knew
and loved and kind of had our hunches
about
this i should point out from the data
that was published uh it seems like the
significance went up significantly to be
redundant
from when there was what five inverse uh
ter of what is it femtoborn
you guys characterize this weird way
luminosity basically almost doubled
and yet the error bar shrank or improved
by
uh something more than a factor of uh
than you'd naively expect so i think
that's quite interesting
anyway we have a comment from mac
matthew is that matthew fox on uh
clubhouse go for it
now are you there
um let's see i have to invite him up i
invited him up
but he is not coming up so
let's see my apologies is my first time
coming up here
no problem matthew go for it we have
have we discovered part of a new
dimension
um i don't know they characterized as a
new dimension a new force james why
don't you take that
potentially could be a new force but i
wouldn't go so far as to say that this
particular measurement
or this again let's make sure this is
not a discovery this is not even an
observation
this is what we call evidence so this is
the cautious optimism that
the message you should take away from
this discovery is that lhcd has not
discovered a new
new particle yet this is a hint for
something um
but i wouldn't say that it has anything
to do so far with
extra dimensions um there are some
potential sort of like very you know
kind of ex
speculative theories that would involve
you know grand unified theories and
and beyond that like extra stuff where
you
you can if you look if you squint just
right and you talk to write theorists
you can kind of explain some of the
the things that we don't understand
about nature with you know for example
new
dimensions of space uh this is not
exactly what is happening here
um but again any new discovery could
point the direction
to where some if sorry any new you know
any new discovery
like for example a discovery of a
violation like this
could in principle point the way as to
where we could then find a discovery
that would relate to things like extra
dimensions so
one of the big things about the standard
model that's one of the biggest
mysteries
is that it has nothing to do with
gravity and we know that gravity exists
so we have so we know is incomplete and
one of the
ways that for example gravity could
could be somehow
uh go with the standard model is if for
example there were other dimensions of
space
that's you know we don't but how that
how that actually happens we currently
have no clue experimentally there's no
way for us to connect those things
what we need first is any kind of hint
any kind of conclusive five to seven
sigma hint that the standard model
has some new thing that we we have
discovered once we find that hint once
we find that portal
the whole game changes and that's when
we might be able to find evidence of
you know really wild things like new
dimensions very cool
so a couple more questions from
clubhouse i'll invite you guys up
alexei and uh
off main is that right in my pronouncing
all right othmain
uh alexei uh alexa go for it you know
what james
sorry i was just passing by and noticed
this is a very interesting
talk and a very interesting discovery uh
my question is maybe a little bit
uh more on the technical side
uh does does the significance of your
result depend on how you beam your
uh your q square distributions
uh yeah phil do you want to take that
and just uh just to reiterate this is
not
uh my guest today phil hilton and and uh
james beecham are not directly
affiliated with this result although
they're both particle physicists
working at the cutting edge at lhc yeah
at cern uh
phil take that uh the dependence and
thinning with respect to q squared
yes it does lest you thought my audience
was mathematically shy guys
come on do i have the best audience in
the world i mean you're getting
questions about q squared bidding
dependence from a new
hummer tip thank you alexa yes go for it
phil
so so yes it does depend upon that uh
and so the bins are carefully chosen
by uh by us when we set up
the the measurement to ensure that we
minimize
theoretical uncertainty and also
experimental uncertainty as well
so this is a very specific way that it's
done
also in terms of the bidding of q
squared at lower values of q squared
uh you are sensitive to what's called
the c prime
nine wilson coefficient this is very
technical jargon but what it means is
you
are you're
too specific in the standard within the
model
whereas at higher q squared uh you you
have more sensitivity to c
prime 10. so these are chosen very
specifically
excellent uh let's see time for one more
question and i have to wrap up the
stream and i know the guys have to go
too it's late at least in europe phil
are you in europe right now
no i'm in uh cincinnati right now you're
in cincinnati okay so you're just in
yeah so this is just this brewer thing
is even more controversial
all right so off main you are our final
uh
questionnaire can you make it quick yeah
absolutely
so um given uh so given
give what will it take basically to
confirm
this result i know that lhcb
like the point in resolution of the
detector is designed in such a way to
pick up these decays
will atlas and cms be able to match that
at least the precision
and if not what will match it besides
lhcp
essentially collecting more data and
then getting
a better resolution for for the
measurement that they have done now
so as an atlas man i can take the first
stab at this one so
atlas and cms will not be able to do the
exact
same uh analysis because of the design
of the detector is slightly different
but we can do a sort of complementary
method
um and i i don't actually know the
answer because it's still being analyzed
right now i can't tell you
you know what atlas is uh planning to
release with respect to this
uh measurement but it likely will be
complementary let's put it that way
i don't think i i don't i would suspect
that with just run two data we wouldn't
be able to
uh make a similar sort of statement um
again i could be totally wrong and so
this is the sort of ambiguity before
um the results become you know before
they're fully vetted inside the
collaboration and then they've become
public
um but i have a suspicion that it's
going to take at least some run three
data for us
to say conclusively uh whether this is
going to be
um this is going to turn into something
if not the high luminosity era and maybe
phil knows more from the lhcb side
whether you're going to need high
luminosity lhc data to really
uh take this to the potentially the five
sigma level or rule out or if it's just
going to be run three
so uh first of all i think before we get
before you were to get really excited
about this
you would absolutely want another
experiment other than lhcp
to to confirm this right this is why we
have multiple experiments
uh on on on the lhc uh and so
um absolutely in terms of cms and atlas
so for example they can reconstruct
electrons differently
and they can do a slightly better job in
reconstructing electrons in certain
scenarios
and so you would really like to see
something come from cms and atlas in
this
in this respect as uh as as you said in
the question
uh the resolution for kind of the
lifetime so
being able to see the b maison in the
first place is not quite so good cms and
atlas weren't designed specifically for
that
but they will be able to see this at
some point one of the
very exciting things about lhc b in
terms of the significance of this result
is that
in the upcoming data taking we've
changed
we're completely changing the way that
lhcb is able to take data and so
we're going to be able to take a whole
bunch more data so while
we're going to be taking roughly uh
double the amount of data that we
currently have or more than double the
amount of data that we currently have
it will be even better than that because
of the way that we're able to to collect
even more data so this is also something
very exciting the other thing i want to
say here though very quickly
is the lhc isn't the whole the only game
in town bell 2
is also online now as well and they have
a very very clean environment and so the
hope would be that they would either be
able to confirm or deny
this anomaly as well awesome guys thank
you so much i can't
thank you guys enough james beecham phil
uh soon to be
at the university of cincinnati uh
phenomenal institution james beacham
uh and i will have many conversations
that are stored on my youtube channel dr
brian keating please go there
subscribe to the channel use your finger
don't get carpal tunnel syndrome in
these radical times
please press the like subscribe button
uh so you avoid that particular malady
uh gentlemen thank you so much for
sharing your time on this exciting day
please agree to come back when you have
new results or anytime you want to come
on
we have the smartest audience in the
multiverse for now
signing off on behalf of my friends uh
all around the world
uh here's to more great scientific
discoveries good night everybody bye-bye